man yeah your day yeah great uh no you
can't wear that what's wrong - you can't
go out in that
what are these are my outside clothes
where's the shirt I bought you that nice
shirt where is it I don't know
well can you just get change please and
turn that off please who is found in
this is the one no I know that's what
you're wearing
okay can you just turn that off please
don't roll your eyes at me I have warned
you right just get to change do you do
I'm not wearing this yes no yes you are
it looks like a bomb it's for sure look
hey remember you wore that two weeks ago
and everyone was saying I look so nice
and answered jimena it's cuz I was
anyone wearing a suit so what you're
wearing okay so just put it on just pop
that one off pop that one on easy I'm
not wearing it I'm not gonna wear
there's no way I'm gonna wear all right
guys you fancy drinking I've got red
white white please I mean which messy
you'll probably have red no red good for
your digestion isn't it
something we're working on ma happy you
drunk MA oh very good isn't it I'd say
brilliant actually
you're so much happier aren't you and
even better he's earning loads more
money than before so we can finally go
on that Mediterranean cruise didn't
think you're into cruises right yes
can't get enough of them don't you live
for them hang on a minute
whoops-a-daisy what's that just me
you've just made it it's you've just got
a bit just let me wear them just let me
slip mean what more so much less painful
if you just let me uh grumpy
anything all right guys just gets a bit
cranky when he's tired and he thinks I'm
fussing but that's normal really don't
always like me but you do love me
you babe don't you tell you wait yeah
yeah yeah
you